thank you so much to the Academy for
this huge honor it means so much to us
and thank you Shawn Denise and Hector
for this amazing week
first I want to introduce you to these
amazing filmmakers up here with me
iris young producer hottie Anya's Vera
production designer Yvonne Shaw editor
Sidney meadow co-writer and zlingly with
cinematographer thank you to our star
Lee or Malka oh hey so the amazing cast
and crew and to everyone who supported
our movie so three number three is
actually based on my experience growing
up in Texas yes this is a Texan accent
y'all as the newly immigrated boy while
I dreamt I'll be coming to the next
Meryl Streep instead because of my
strong Israeli accent I was cast as
flour number four lamp number two and
sad cloud number six so I decided to put
up my own plays in our small living room
and invite my own crowd in those plays
at home I cast myself as the lead no
drama teacher was going to convince me
that I was doomed to be background
forever making this film was our way to
prove it but this movie wouldn't exist
without all those people who saw me as
more than sad cloud number six first
Michael urban RAF I mentor well who
always encouraged us to keep the things
that others questioned the best stuff in
the movie are the things we got the most
notes on and they're all still there
because of you so thank you Michael for
believing in us so much and being the
best mentor ever thank you to my mom and
dad every dream I ever had came true
because of you
when I said I wanted to be a dancer you
found me the best ballet school in Texas
do you know how hard that is y'all when
I said I didn't get a part in the school
play you built a stage in our living
room and got me a sold-out audience you
told me that that the capacity was five
which meant sold out
and when I said I wanted to move abroad
and study at AFI even though I knew we
couldn't really afford it you said well
it's cheaper than USC third I want to
thank AFI before moving the year I had
never slept out of my house and was
terrified I won't make it here but AFI
turned out to be the best home I could
have could have asked for literally the
restrooms are so much cleaner than in my
house the AC usually always sometimes
works and there's always an animal to
feel a deer a coyote or a first-year
student and at 11 p.m. and we were
working late hours at AFI people would
come and ask don't you want to go home I
would say that I'm already there I'd
like to think Patti west susan dretke
Vanessa Hayes Peter Markham Barrie
Sabbath Rob Spira Andrew Wagner and
everyone at AFI and lastly I want to
share this award with all those who are
still put in the background with the
outsider seeking acceptance when it
seems impossible and we've the dreamers
who will do whatever it takes to prove
to the world that a tree isn't just a
tree
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]